mir geht's einfach um ein paar ganz
simple Tatsachen die ich nicht erfunden
oder gefunden habe das Schöne an der
Situation der wir leben ist alles wird
öffentlich und wenig wird wahrgenommen
also die Fakten liegen auf dem Tisch man
muss sich nicht mal tief beugen sie
aufzuheben und maßgeblich für die
Situation die wir jetzt haben ist der
Euro und die Europäische Zentralbank die
uns seit Jahren erzählt es gibt ein Ziel
ein Zielvorgabe nämlich eine 2%
Inflation die Preise dürfen nicht drüber
steigen aber nicht drunter liegen und
ich habe mal Zitate gesammelt von einer
Direktorin der Europäischen Zentralbank
von der deutschen sozusagen von unserer
Vertretung im Olymp des europäischen
Geschäfts Isabel Schnabel die noch vor
einem Jahr gesagt hat ja man rechnet
damit das im kommenden Jahr die
Inflation sich wieder rückentwickeln
wird das ist so als würde ein
Wetterexperte sagen ja ne Lawine du
schon unten ist kann man wieder dazu
bewegen wieder nach oben zu rollen oder
man kann sie auf halber Strecke gezeigt
und diese Wirtschafts- und Finanzpolitik
der Europäischen Zentralbank in
Verbindung mit den Brüchen aller
Abkommen alle europäischen Abkommen auch
das maastrichtvertrages hat dazu geführt
dass wir jetzt von dieser sandkasse
stehen ich habe vorhin das schon glaube
ich angedeutet wenn die Europäische
Zentralbank Milliarden Euro in den Markt
pumpt dann wird nicht mal ein
volkswirtschaftsstudent im ersten
Semester damit rechnen dass das keine
Inflation gibt natürlich gibt das
Inflation dass es ein Naturgesetz dafür
muss man nicht Caes oder oder ein oder
Milton Friedman studiert haben das ist
ebenso und das ist hier einfach völlig
aus der Sicht aus dem Blick verschwunden
und das zweite habe ich auch schon
angedeutet der Staat gilt als ein
Wirtschaftsteilnehmer ein teilnehmender
sagt man glaube ich heute ja er ist es
nicht er verteilt nur das Geld um der
Staat produziert kein Mehrwert der hat
kein Geld der nimmt Geld ein und gibt
Geld aus und hier hat sich eben die
Ansicht Grundgesetz dass der Staat Geld
hat es gibt auch eine moderne monetaris
theory den nun wirklich ganz nah bei
David Copperfield siedelt Leute können
Zaubernde dieser Theorie vertreten dass
der Stadt so viele Schulden machen kann
wie er will und das
EZB hat keine Strategie damit verfolgt
also die letzten Jahre und Jahrzehnte
ich glaube die hat keine Strategie
verfolgt dazu sind die Leute nicht
intelligent genug die sind einfach
irgendeine Zielvorgabe hinterher gerannt
und glaubten es wird schon klappen ist
eine harte Behauptung ja eine weichere
habe ich gerade nicht zur Hand aber
lassen Sie mich nachdenken in Köln hat
man immer gesagt es ist noch immer Jod
gegangen
das Motto das demnächst über dem Eingang
zur Europäischen Zentralbank eingraviert
wird würden sie damit gehen dass das
Motto der EZB ist es immer gut gegangen
nein das glaube ich nicht ich glaube da
steht natürlich dahinter dass die EZB
auch
EU-Politik macht und letztendlich sind
da ja sehr unterschiedliche Bedürfnisse
in der EU die gedeckt werden wir wollen
ja man möchte natürlich nicht dass
diejenigen die jetzt viele Schulden
haben dass sie die Schulden nicht mehr
zurückzahlen können und die Frage ist
allerdings ob das die Aufgabe der EZB
ist ist es eben nicht eben aber sie
tut's ja ja man nennt das glaube ich die
Kraft des Faktischen oder so ähnlich ja
haben sie denn einen Lösungsvorschlag
oder wenn wir hier immer über die
Probleme reden was wäre die Lösung
die Aufgabe der EZB ist soweit ich das
verstanden habe als nicht Finanzexpertin
die Stabilität des Finanzmarktes zu
garantieren und nicht das Geld zu
verteilen nach anderen politischen
Erfordernissen und das könnte man
eigentlich von der EZB erwarten darf ich
kurz vielleicht mit einem Satz von
Isabel Schnabel zitieren die Menschen
und die Unternehmen im Euroraum sollen
sich darauf verlassen können dass Geld
stabil ist dass also ihr Geld morgen
ungefähr genauso viel wert ist wie heute
ja und das ist ja wohl zwei Jahren
gesagt ja
und jetzt würden Sie sagen da muss sie
sich jetzt für entschuldigen für den
Satz entschuldigen ich Entschuldige ich
kann mich entschuldigen auf dem Fuß
dreht aber dafür muss man sich nicht
entschuldigen dafür haben die Japaner
ein anderes Verfahren erfunden welches
denn Harakiri ja okay
Frau Seibert wie wenn sie jetzt blicken
als Bürgerin darauf fühlen sie sich
dennoch sicher was das Geld betrifft
nein überhaupt nicht also ich hoffe
einfach dass es gut geht aber ich glaube
man muss sich halt vorsehen also ich
würde mich jetzt nicht wundern wenn
wieder die Hamsterkäufe losging und
nicht nur was das Toilettenpapier angeht
sondern im großen Stil ich kenne auch
einige die das schon gemacht haben das
haben die so gekauft einfach Konserven
Lebensmittel für zwei drei Monate also
wie gesagt ich habe noch nichts in
Richtung unternommen weil sie hatten als
der Hamster
ich bin gesund aber es gibt Hamsterkäufe
die jetzt schon auch wieder erledigt
werden die sie auch kennen wo man sagt
und es ist viele haben sich tatsächlich
noch schnell einen Kachelofen einbauen
lassen oder so was man sich dann ins
Wohnzimmer stellt Kamin haben Holz
gekauft oder eben diese Gas Dinger also
nicht was sie jetzt erzählt haben mit
mit in die Steckdose stecken sondern
wirklich was mit Gasflaschen
ja ich wie gesagt ich bin da noch nicht
eingestiegen aber ich glaube schon dass
es jetzt bitte jetzt ist zu spät
haben Sie auch schon Hamsterkauf
erledigt oder sagen Sie ne mache ich
nicht also ich habe mir das
schnell also ich fand es immer
bemerkenswert wenn ich durch den
Supermarkt gelaufen bin und dann lief
ich an leeren Regalen vorbei letzte Mal
als ich lehre Regale gesehen hatte war
das wenn irgendwie früher im DDR
Fernsehen Supermärkte oder Kaufhallen
wie es ja geheißen hat gezeigt worden
sind und ansonsten konnte ich mich daran
nicht erinnern oder wenn ich auf Kuba
war da war das dann auch so also das
fand ich schon schräg ehrlich also
damals und weiß auch nicht ob das damals
wirklich so notwendig gewesen ist und
wenn ich aber auch ehrlich sein darf
jetzt fehlt mir irgendwie das
Verständnis oder wie soll ich sagen ich
kann es wenig beurteilen ob das nun
sinnvoll oder nicht sinnvoll ist und ich
habe es einfach für mich immer so
gehalten dass ich mich dann der Stimme
enthalte wenn ich es einfach nicht
beurteilen kann aber macht die Inflation
ihnen denn Angst nein die macht mir
jetzt nicht so viel Angst aber ich sehe
natürlich in meinem Umfeld was passiert
ich sehe wie wie Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das mir sagen und das macht
mich schon betroffen
auch hier vielleicht habe ich eine
Minderheiten Meinung aber ich sehe die
Inflation galoppiert klar das sehe ich
schon und das ist auch schlimm wenn ich
aber sehe was momentan woanders noch
Inflation los ist wenn ich von 20 bis 30
Prozent Inflation höre
beispielsweise Russland wobei natürlich
Russland ja ein sehr spezieller Fall ist
dann sage ich auch es geht uns
vergleichsweise noch einigermaßen wenn
ich sehe wie es woanders abläuft über
wie gesagt
unsere longturm kann ich das nicht
beurteilen das muss zugeben
jagen sie mich nicht darauf fest ob ich
Optimist oder Pessimist bin ich halte
wirklich so wie ich sage wenn ich Dinge
nicht beurteilen kann dann rede ich
darüber nicht finde ich ein Optimist ist
jemand der noch nie überfallen wurde
und dann seine Geldbörse hergeben muss